action wait isn't that the movie with
the cult following where the cult
following doesn't even realize that it
has the cold white has goddammit
with a couple of cold foaming doesn't
know why he has the cult following okay
alright ready mm-hm and action
wait isn't that the movie with the cult
following that the goddammit I miss it
wait isn't that the movie where the cult
following doesn't even know fuck what is
it huh edit know that wait isn't that
the movie with the cult following where
even the cult following doesn't know why
it has a cult following
oh yes and according to the same
directors MORTAL KOMBAT hell something
yeah how can even I get him I see happen
wait isn't that the movie with the cult
following where even the cult following
doesn't know why it has a cult following
oh yes and according to the same
director as mortal kombat hell can even
exist space really oh yes my friend I'm
going to get through this okay now that
that's deadly wait isn't that the movie
with the cult following where even the
cult following doesn't know why it has a
cult following oh yes
and according to the same director as
Mortal Kombat hell can even exist in
space really oh yes my friend
that sounds like really lazy design work
never you turn the Tamara I would have
won all right and actually wait isn't
that the movie with the cult following
where even the cult following doesn't
know why it has a cult following oh yes
but even the director of MORTAL KOMBAT
so something wait wait isn't that the
movie with the cult following where even
the cult following does it know why it
has a cult following oh yes
and according to the director of Mortal
Kombat hell can even exist in space
really oh yes my friend that sounds like
really lazy design work good oh you sure
the first time you turned your tail
right just go ahead okay keep it there
yeah I'll get the mouth on the first end
yeah okay um I'm getting better at it
wait isn't that the movie with the cult
following where even the cult following
doesn't know why it has a cult following
oh yes and according to the director of
Mortal Kombat even held something fuck
even exist in space and actually wait a
minute isn't that the movie with the
cult following where even the cult
following doesn't know why it has a cult
following oh yes and according to the
director of Mortal Kombat hell can even
exist in space
I wasn't ready for you all right okay
sorry ready and action
wait isn't that the movie with the cult
following or even the cult following
doesn't know why it has a cult following
oh yes
and according to the director of Mortal
Kombat hell can even exist in space
really yes my friend oh that sounds like
really lazy design work on yours Malcolm
Sato look clear oh that's good and uh I
send the lot I mean like this is gonna
be good just be like oh I feel like even
bigger even goofier
the same Ramon was really good yeah and
action
wait a minute isn't that the movie with
the cult following where even the cult
following doesn't know why it has a cult
following oh yes and according to the
director of Mortal Kombat hell can even
exist in space really yes my friend
[Music]
that sounds like really lazy design work
action wait isn't that the movie with
the cult fuck ready all right ready ha
and action
wait a minute isn't that the movie with
the cult following where even the cult
following doesn't know why there's a
cult following oh yes and according to
the director of Mortal Kombat hell can
even exist in space really yes my friend
[Music]
that sounds like really lazy design work
what have you done this time what have I
done this time I've turned five years
old pretty much this is a bridge away I
think well cuz you saw in the script
Malcolm white I didn't have anything
else just like the critic walks into
kitchen gets candy falls over screaming
or something like this it's like I
forgot about this so I incorporated this
um I'm here and I want to use in the
stache' ween uh then um then I was just
like oh I gotta get Count Chocula all
that stuff in there so I made this
concoction of Count Chocula blueberry
Franken berry and a Reese's Peanut
Butter Cup on top with chocolate milk of
course and good honestly if you're
wondering what it tastes like uh it
tastes like chocolate covered
strawberries the cereal it's actually
not that bad surprises like chocolate
covered fruit so I mean not that I would
recommend because you know you'll
probably die with just one bite but uh
if you're really looking for death by
chocolate so good death by chocolate
death by chocolate I know the fuck are
you there's a wall there introduce
yourself say you are alright hey um I'm
better again yes this is my second time
doing this thing for the outtakes or
whatever this is called the
behind-the-scenes scene that's what the
cache started
yes I've gotta try it you'll die dad
you're a diabetic yes we think the die
in diabetic I was working on the joke at
those game the plug it out just like
yeah I'm just like just museum yeah it's
that you kind of not that bad
that's terrible really ha ha ha Wow
camera you try you try this is all the
the Frankenberry the blueberry and Count
Chocula wit chocolate milk all the Halal
all combined oh yes this is hello the
two diabetics I would not eat this yeah
we're gentlemen oh yeah am I the only
one that's my veto oh yeah I don't think
you chamber I don't think so oh yeah
portal man awesome
good night everybody
no but nobody likes my idea I like that
is combination of the fruity monsters
and Count Chocula has one super monster
and just called like chocolate-covered
strawberry cue walk now nobody likes us
Dulli okay I write till I found berry
berry you I would try it but the
marshmallows I don't eat marshmallows
you'll need marshmallows no well only if
it's a certain type of marshmallow cuz
yeah it's just it's animal they left
yeah it's a love don't break really yeah
that's why I know the gelatin is made
with like animal homes isn't it yeah
it's just left over the leftovers scram
now I don't want any --it no no don't
get up yellow it's a really discuss more
now your daddy I know where our
marshmallows marshmallows okay yeah no
system energy I think you all know they
probably do you still have that yeah I
think this is just like condensed
marshmallows are teddy bear balls huh
there we go thank you for that image
you're given thanks be hungry
mmm bear balls but yeah I do like this
shirt a friend of mine actually owns I
sure that the exact shirt actually
really yeah oh good is that oh this is
oh you really need and I don't know this
and I like you who knew best
thank you yes I'm good I gotta represent
yeah representin yeah you got a select I
won't really really really need to get a
girl yeah no no wait that's our ball we
say we're gonna get one for you and then
we're gonna get the devil
sure for you to you are yeah oh yeah not
in person Joe to the verge of being
hyper began girl yeah
and they'll give you the discount rate
did you notice that
another thing that he's got on yeah look
at the look at the cranial care tree
that looks like the Grinch
ah wait what the guy looks like the
Grinch look at them do them those frown
down there and the big nose don't see it
quite I mean it's offensive
no I mean you shake it up it's like well
I got it uh hey Manny
who's the girl but nobody knows you know
the reason why you're looking at this
has a nose look at that as that's his
mouth okay now can you see the Grinch ha
ha ha all right guys here to talk about
candy eyes thank you yeah kind of maybe
nursery oh there's they're gonna do like
what yeah that would you Barney joke
sleep
you got a grin to your shirt
ah they are going into the next room
into the lounge area breakfast of
champions
um really should be creepy yeah
and each other growing up if my dad and
future you might evil laugh not
intentionally but here we hear me doing
it he would know that I was like
tormenting my little brother you would
want me to be like camera stuff and I'd
always be tormenting you cuz I've got
like a regular laugh and I've got like a
normal it's just a terrible evil
sinister laughter Sarah will you believe
us okay let's get you movie with your
sister Wow the studio is so cleaned up
yeah even more than when Robert did it
even more than when Rob was in here
[Music]
Oh VIN horizon I've heard about it I
never actually saw it the scene is
pretty much the guy he's kind of like in
a daze and he goes into the airlock he's
gonna like shoot himself out of the
airlock um you know into space pretty
much takes place in space and they call
him baby bear just real weird and he
calls him like mama bear and Papa bears
it's really creepy so you're gonna be
there but I suggest me the reason you're
throwing stuff out the airlock is
because the fucking calling you baby
bear because this isn't like a little
kid I mean you think he's like a
teenager he's you know what the youngest
like college student or something like
that by means a fucking astronaut so
it's gonna be pretty awful right I'm
gonna be like back here so talking like
through the door okay kind of thing so
by in the whole time you're just looking
the air like I told you here we call me
baby bear
thank you talking mom mm-hmm so you're
pretty much just looking you know like
but pretty much it Beto there okay so
you've been up there
no no oh baby bear Evy Beto bear
movingly Barney bear uh no Barney we're
yeah yeah okay yeah so you're mostly
yeah just definitely them they weren't
coming off are they go getting this bro
okay yeah a whole bet that frowny faces
are good I think you ready come on baby
bear I told you I hate what you call me
baby bear all right we'll call you
smoochy kids father come ah how do you
hmm hey I know shrieky balls used to
love it when we call your shrinky balls
yeah smile free without the idea hi
Jason yes it's evening it's our jerk
your head back a little bit to it
yourself oh okay so just kind of like
yeah and I said he did keep the UM
probably a little less teeth and more
just like you're trying to keep it
working mmm yeah yes come on back baby
bear
I told you a hitter when you call me
baby bear they're really angry just you
know I told you it you know you're gonna
fucking kill yourself you're so stunned
about this okay okay ready
come on back baby bar I told you I hate
when you call me baby bear all right
we'll go you smoochy kids buttercup I
know cue balls used to love them we
called your shrinky balls good when you
hit it be sure that you hit it and then
you get something that with like so just
me so yes ready come on baby bear I told
you I hate it when you call me baby bear
all right I'll call you smoochy kids
buttercup honey lemon all right trade
you balls use the longer when we call
your shrinky balls all right
um go ahead get um get change now that
into the devil outfit I miss you
one or two quickly no not the double yes
so how'd that feel and it felt very
Spacey Kevin oh okay go go ahead sis
which it towards you dad you're gonna be
cameraman I don't really need a limp
your legs there what what what it's
gonna be I'm gonna be on the ground and
fire is like big ball of fire gonna be
coming on my ass wave ripples of fun
very much yes alright so like maybe
Louis 5 folder Sonya uh probably
probably not gonna be moving around a
lot um I think it should be all right
just keep eye out if it does go on focus
I don't think it's party though you
ready yeah rolling okay can you up can
you move your whole body one foots that
way you can cover up a big yes good yes
okay you're wrong
I see you later okay it pulled up on
your left side pull the coat down yep no
pull it down further
yes there you go that yes all right okay
rolling the tray one wait hold on
pull women yes all right we're going to
rolling okay
this Nikki one now maybe yeah how is our
pretty boy yeah
I don't know what to make of this just
where we're going the direction you
always thought we would go we're going
into porn ah yes I knew it as did I I've
been watching since I've been in high
school oh my a little bit um okay uh
your camera scene I kept I can't be
dyeing my hair blue much anymore I'm 25
that money
I just turned 69 what's that tell you
well that's weird because like you know
I don't sing like you know yeah I used
to watch you when I was like sophomore
in high school I'm just like oh yes oh
I've read all my first video was on the
good son review yeah yeah what I didn't
I guess there's a lot a lot of people
like oh yeah don't fucking talk it I
love that one doctor fucking blessed
yeah um try that I see there's any kind
of I can play so you're like already in
front of camera oh pretty much you're
like bending over angles like bending
put is more like all right I like face
the camera oh yeah there you go
Oh oops
no that's fine um actually I'll show you
something here you sure you did the spot
focus right dad
yes on you yeah okay like do you mind
sure they bend over grab it this place
needs a plant like walk this way yeah
good like this
yeah go ahead bring in the frame Lacey
do you mind a remodeling well but you
leave the plant on the ground you don't
actually bring it into frame until the
second time okay so so so much yeah so
when I say action you're starting to
bend over and then you see the camera do
you my memory modeling shoe and then you
bend over this place needs a plan all
right okay ready and action
do you mind I'm remodeling this place
ends up that good oh oh just a hint
louder on this place needs a plant but
uh that's good and even at the few minor
remodeling you know you can yell a
little bit into your mind okay this is I
mean it doesn't have to be like yell
yell but give you know to bind I'm
remodeling okay all right ready and
action
oh wait I'm sitting right ready and edge
do you mind a remodeling this place it's
a plant
good say it as you're walking off this
place needs a play oh that's good
and action do you mind
I'm remodeling this place needs a plant
good a little bit more I like the way
you said before the little ready and
action
do you mind I'm remodeling this place
needs a polite okay yeah I was a good
one okay only one with the set it there
Tracy the flowers with the teddy bear
odd I think we can just do the bending
over saying this place needs a teddy
bear because like oh that's true yeah so
I mean you'll still it's like after the
snap so you're still facing the camera
okay okay ready and action
this place needs a teddy bear that's
very high - okay I'll do that one good
put him down Malcolm and a cute this
place needs a teddy bear
good one more a little bit more of the
Cortinas
no like I said this place these oh I
like this place needs an air freshener
needs a little this ready and actually
this place could use a
good alright this is going to be audio
only um I'm gonna have you shout I'm
putting in a plant and then we'll do an
hour version I'm putting in a teddy bear
so this is only audio okay and you know
it shouted cuz this is your Prima
shouting from my ass alright so we'll do
the plan first ready mm-hmm
and action I'm putting in a plant good
stretch it out a bit
I'm putting in a plant good and I like
that I'm putting in a plant good ah do
tell you hear I'm putting in a teddy
bear good knowing I'm putting in a teddy
bear good bit more angry I'm putting in
a teddy bear
ah screaming more okay I'm putting in a
teddy bear good on teddy bear as a bear
and go better I'm putting in a teddy
bear okay I'm putting in a teddy bear
good one more like that I'm putting in a
teddy bear
good all right I'll go to the next bit
oh there's more yeah this is still
recording better mm-hmm
yeah big toe
bear okay you you've replaced me no I'm
making a bunion Doug just taking my bike
I'm watching you you can't watch me nice
okay so sorry is like a so I say let's
see so at the end of the review is in
speaking of hell you think of relocating
any time soon are you looking
and we'll go from there okay all right I
see you make sure the focus is still
okay yeah 25 seconds left
oh uh yeah let me see well the smell is
pretty bad even for me but I can't just
go without leaving you with some form of
suffering put hell on my ass how much
more suffering can you get than that
fine I have been scouting under William
Shatner's toupee
alright I'll head out oh thank god
I mean you whatever good oh yes oh you
go get out of there for a bit and this
works so we done with green screen it is
a really cool jacket though yeah that's
why it's a little why that's the only
thing it's an extra-large I guess it was
like only thing they had er was too
small right yeah it was okay in the
shoulders for the sleeve like what I'm
like this the sleeves were like mmm okay
yeah that one they definitely stay so
let's go I really want to use this last
year but I already started nostalgia
when I'm like I look weird but just
started halfway through so that's Boston
now now looks totally normal
oh but yeah so I definitely really like
it Tamra can you look at my ass to see
if he'll is still there I'm gonna be a
backup singer for brentalfloss just do
it mm-hmm
whoa by Stephen King oh because I'm
apparently okay that there's a book up
that's okay by Stephen King book oh no
it's one of two movies it's either it's
either dreamcatcher or I I think that
was wrong that's true ah crap that's a
really good comparison yeah or the other
which I kind of want to do more because
merit being so funny children of a corn
I think more people probably click on
that to the porn that well it's
something where it's like I remember
them I just barely remember the movie I
come every was like so bad it was good
or anything like that but that rah-rah W
member Hezekiah I'm like holy shit yes I
remember is it coming out we can't do
this movie now because I'm not like yeah
the kid actors were just so into it yeah
and I was just like yeah I think that
could actually probably be really funny
uh I get the pen just more people would
click on it to get a title more people
know as well are we doing any clips
clip please you mean yeah uh we might do
goosebumps it kinda fit the goosebumps
movie oh yeah tying it a little bit with
the show in the books as well um but it
kind of pay if I watch it and I'm just
like I can't get anything out of this
and like whatever nobody watches ever
talks about I'll just be like game you
know what we'll just do a regular review
um but uh yeah but after that we'll be
the commercial special which yeah that's
right another one yeah no we do whatever
I gosh it's so cool this is just yeah
well we use you to them around November
cuz that's close to like Christmas Diane
as well so tones commercial like sad
I like the Thanksgiving time and
everything so yeah no I love doing those
um that's one of the reasons I always
only do one a year cuz I know if I do
too many I'll get sick of them it's like
no no just good timing out nicely yes
fun dress coming run yay commercial
special oh cool definitely yeah hey you
get to be part of that yes yes no I got
it
we haven't told it doesn't oh hey you're
doing great you're doing great he's not
gonna be at all to it wonderful you're
not gonna be in the special shit sorry
Tara are we ready we'll get over here
yep
oh no no I'm fighting back come on teach
your interns like that minute hey so
you're going meatballs now yeah it looks
good Thank You Malcolm
you say I just brought up an observation
you are doing meatballs now assume
pumpkins now today
here is your room thank you like oh yeah
we're all gonna get that exactly I don't
even uh okay
oh you're going to be in the doorway
here and I'm gonna say um I'm gonna say
Tamra you're just peeking from behind
the corn I'm gonna be pretty much where
Malcolm is you know and you're at a peak
and I'm gonna say look at my ass and see
if he'll is still there just you hold a
reaction you just say I'm gonna go be a
backup singer for brentalfloss oh I said
just do it and you're walking that's it
okay hey you ready and Tamra look at my
ass and see if he'll is still there I'm
gonna go be a backup singer for
brentalfloss I'm gonna kill who's ever
phone went off
[Music]
[Applause]
haha my people may vibrate party society
this is when there's a disturbance yeah
okay ready yeah
Tamra lookups on my ass and see if he'll
is still in there yeah I'm gonna go be a
back I've seen her for brentalfloss just
do it good have sort of a you had a
wonderful look in the Oh what the hell
was that the monster squad one were
after we took the door you just had this
look
yeah just see if you can get that yeah
look at my CFLs here just hope they look
I'm gonna be Beckett yeah just kind of
like confused and discussed it at the
same time ready yes
and Tamra look up my ass and see if
he'll is still there yeah I'm gonna go
be a backup singer for brentalfloss just
do it
great we'll do one more just receive
great yeah good Tara look up my ass and
see if he'll is still there
yeah I'm gonna go be a backup singer for
brentalfloss just do it good okay let's
see I am going to actually need this
stuff off Oh get it was all day same
with me okay uh Tammy did you back over
here you are going to look up my ass
Oh that'll be a disaster
alright that's the first times we sit
yeah example so for asked over yeah yeah
so pretty yeah that there you go so we
won't be sure that you're in the
so yeah go like this and see there's
nothing in there but a book I go oh you
say by Stephen King oh he did it that's
what makes it so good I'll just sit here
waiting for Tamra to look up my ass
though
okay alright there's nothing there's
just a book yeah there's nothing in
there but a book whoa by Stephen King oh
okay so go ahead sir go back to the
palette up oh yeah yeah the doorway
there Larry ready yeah and action
there's nothing in there it's just a
book whoa by Stephen King oh good Jenna
ready and action
there's nothing in there but a book whoa
by Stephen King oh good I try one more
you were biting there's nothing in there
but a book whoa by Stephen King oh good
yeah see that's not the weirdest thing
you've done who hasn't had a Stephen
King book up their ass all right
Cheyenne's jaw yeah okay um we're gonna
go in the kitchen real fast we're gonna
do the scene where you guys I guess we
can actually do great to Jim scene first
the more I think about it um with the
doctor cause it does take place in here
I'll do the kitchen darkness
yeah whereas you can do it like yeah
right and pretty much what it was yeah
a colonoscopy or something Oh Priya he's
just looking up there
this is a second that is indeed hell up
your ass yes appears to be an ass
what's your money down crack in the
middle consider what you're looking at
Jim does this make you a holistic doctor
but uh Barney Oh Jim's taking this oh
well here's method acting good I hope
you're a method actor trouble oh uh no
there's a light on there right yeah okay
you're so much ass you were its
assistant okay um yes this is just just
one shot Franz just the shot we had with
me here my business name position change
yeah shut this at the board over a
storia keep coming up that's yummy you
can get in cleaning yeah ask me no
questions I'll tell you no lies
yes is seeping kind of cheated a little
bit here I'll show you the shot there
yeah so I like I'm gonna be knocking
yeah there you yeah yeah I do like it
like you just pulled out I'll just do do
you like I just pull up my hand out yeah
it's like sure oh yeah yeah you gotta
put the other glove on this just this is
real nass this is just nice all you're
gonna do is since I say action
oh I was like he'll see damsels look at
you see ya we're IQ wins that was um
okay so yeah just act like you still
still hard to see you see see there you
go yeah can wear like that and a see if
you can chief a little bit more towards
the wall yeah there you go okay
so yeah like that and then when I say
action just act like you you know why
put your hand out yeah very Sir Michael
like that just yeah dude and then you
start to walk over that way
okay yeah so I don't do a line incorrect
do you just walk in this one alright
ready mmm-hmm and action thoughtful he
just like going to watch I'd be in this
position okay good as you can get what
shit like this that was good
alright uh she a little bit more to the
wall Jim there you go
all right ready I'm Chris alright ready
and action
a little slow in your reaction was i
okay I'll try one more yeah I wasn't I
wasn't totally looking at the camera
there let me say now and then
simultaneously Jim will can move and you
guys are good idea okay all right good
all right ready Jim and okay
now good yeah lucky solid yeah why not
yeah you do one more input put a bunch
of what about what it's like he got like
stuck in there's like triangle 101 I'll
do it
cheat cheat a little bit more to the
wall yeah there we go
all right you're still gonna do the now
dead yep all right ready and action
and now nice yeah so ah I mean so like
go right into it club okay so we're
gonna run towards barrel uh yeah but you
probably won't get out of the way
therefore and we are not screaming
correct correct I mean if you want to do
like it like that that's fine but no
Angela screaming on this one so oh right
anyway in the frame like where am I
yeah about right there that's perfect
and then when they turn around yeah you
can sort of just turn around to maybe
just like it just in your glass you're
not real yeah okay you know what well I
guess I know I'm gonna forget I'm gonna
have you both just do the yelling now
see just go
[Music]
you know for like ten seconds okay all
right so it's gonna be one two three and
all that stuff okay ready one two three
Yuto it's all you I'm sorry what point I
don't agree yeah your head word job my
job all right you ready yes Hey one two
three good Oh
you're both were movable there and you
don't want to that bolt you should have
had different sounds or just if he does
on a retreat you just so yeah
uh yeah I'm right the closer they can be
together the bear so you know one two
three oh okay
you're murdering you're not being
murdered now whatever okay ready and one
two three okay
all right so we'll do the actual uh see
you think all right so weapons out of
frame
[Music]